fifth week is a time in Oxford when all
students are struck down by an epidemic
it's called the fifth week blues
students get depressed because they
realize they're only halfway through the
term it's still four more weeks to go
bring it on
well let's get on with things
so absolutely loads of Susman going on
this week in terms of the work this is
actually the first week all the term
where I haven't had a problem she doing
so I've actually been able to
concentrate properly on my Master's
project also in physics news on Thursday
we had the physics society a talk by dr.
vodka vara who gave a talk called
quantum computers have plants got their
first on Friday we had a performance
from the Oxford imps who do improvised
comedy and I just got to watch it hour
and a half of unbelievably funny stuff
completely for free you're not Jase yeah
because a couple of themes go to some
Peters or so because they're friends
with one of our welfare officers they
just said yeah we'll come in and do
something they do things like they'll
set up a scene and they'll ask for stuff
for millions so for the last sketch that
they did they asked the audience for a
location which somebody said was a
postbox and a thing like a man and
somebody said hedgehog and completely
off the cuff they then proceeded to act
out a play called the hedgehog and the
postbox
I had a coherent plot it have recurring
characters it had songs which they did
on the spot with musical accompaniment
they had a penis how does that what now
somebody asked in the comments I think
it was last week where's my favorite
cafe Oxford and Jamie you also asked me
if only enough where's my favorite a
place to eat in Oxford so I thought I'd
go through a couple of places so a
couple of years ago the biochemistry
department office we've just got a
completely new building and the
equipment crammed through a really nice
cafe which anybody in university in co2
in fact a lot of people in the science
there of all these science departments
will notice the science departments all
in the same area go to for lunch and
they do really nice quiches which is the
healthy option which I try and go for
for kids I'm trying these away but there
was only ever gonna be one minute for me
in the best place to where you know it's
food it's not a cafe it's not really a
restaurant it's it's a way of life I'm
getting wistful just thinking about it
my favorite place to eat you know it is
without a shadow of a doubt atomic
burger now atomic burger is a restaurant
on Cowley Road which unfortunately means
that it's a bit
far away for me to walk from some
features to get some pushes just to the
outside but I have some visited the
inside because me and a friend went and
did their fall out challenge a couple of
months ago
now the fall out challenge is allegedly
the world's hottest burger on the
Scoville rating scale which lists bell
peppers at like 15 a hot chilli would be
a couple of thousand police pepper spray
is two million the fallout challenge
roots formula and I've never experienced
pain like it the reason that I love a
song about me so much it's the culture
of it it's basically big geek cafe and
as somebody who's unashamedly nerdy I
love that like any place that has a
Carbonite Han Solo on the wall as
decoration is a is fine by me there are
other really good places in Oxford that
I haven't mentioned actually Oh like
Jean Dee's I should mention Jean DS
because that's an Oxford chain of ice
cream parlors which are famous in Oxford
for just being awesome and actually
there is another place which is brothers
cafe in the cupboard market it lies
between Cole Market Street which is like
our main shopping street and the high
street and it's a covered market of
about 50 independent shops so you've got
butchers
you've got fashion shops you've got
gardening shops florists artists and the
world's greatest cake shop and it's
generally it's one of these places in
Oxford that you don't get told about
it's quite a well-kept secret to people
that don't actually go to Oxford it's so
different from staying at a library
basically it's so vibrant I just keep
the counter of it for pick where you
take that okay so I'm running out of
time in this video so I better get on to
my question to you guys the viewers so I
noticed in some of the comments before
that people were referencing other
communities in YouTube like we had some
of the chaos our army we had some no
fighters very CLE I am a no fart I'm
also about the ksi army I'm Pablo two
different online communities I'd be
interested to know what kind of
communities you guys are interested in
because I'd like you guys to start
talking to each other as love and Jamie
um I was surprised to read in the
newspaper that some your war some cats
has declared war on modeling um so I
guess my question to you is
are you alive I think that's it for this
week just sticking around guys I will
see you next Sunday and Jamie I might
see you on Thursday